[Music]
okay everyone i'm really really excited
today
because i am being joined by hollywood
royalty
and he goes by the name of frankie
grande frankie how are you doing today
oh my god i'm so much better now you
just called me hollywood royalty my god
that's all the titles were observed
people like
betty davis you know joan crawford my
goodness
but i do you know i think i've always
had hollywood royalty inside of me so
i'm just grateful that you brought it
out today
yes it's finally blooming fully and it's
fully realized and
i'm excited because you're you're in
this new movie spree that came out today
and i was watching this movie and i i
was just wondering in my head
how did this role come about for you
because it does really feel like the
movie you would fit
to be cast in because you are someone
who's very experienced with social media
yes it really was so originally i
auditioned
to play the role of kurt but i think
that when i send my tape in like they
were already talking to joe carrey who's
part like he it was supposed to be joe
carey he might have even already been
cast he's wonderful um but when eugene
saw my tape he was like frank he has to
be in the movie so we have to basically
create a character for him
um and so they did and they created this
character of richard who
and the character breakdown it says um
vainly beautiful so i just like to say
that just
like to say that that was the that's the
character i was passed that is mainly
beautiful i think it's wonderful
um but he's uh you know and and
basically just a
party boy who is hey and his
three his two best girlfriends decide to
go out in the town and like in
specifically to find things to post on
social media
to get likes and to cause uh ruckus
and certainly they get what they asked
for i know they certainly do get what
they've asked for
yeah so all the things you described
there about richard's character a really
good breakdown on your part
do you feel a lot of frankie and richard
well i feel a lot of old frankie and
richard i will say that
um you know after broadway you know i
had this period where i was um
a youtuber for two and a half years
where all i did was
conceive shoot edit and post youtube
videos twice a week
and i was a monster i can go ahead and
say that right now
like you know just tripping videos at
disney world anything to get people to
to like to reply and to you know do
anything in order to become famous and
get those likes like
that was my that was my only goal um
during those two and a half years and
um you know it got me to big brother
which then took me to the next phase of
my career um and then that unhealthy
relationship with social media then
got passed on to twitter and instagram
where i kind of had the same
unhealthy behavior and then you know
about three years ago i had
the just i made the decision to get
sober and
yeah i'm three years older now thank you
so much uh three years and two months we
count
every single day in this program so i
literally in that in that time
and that that self-reflective period of
my life
i all i really had to re-examine my
relationship to social media
um and that why it was contributing to
my
deep unhappiness and my desire to drink
and use
was all interconnected into this
weird realm of fame and social media and
hunger and i'm so proud to say that my
relationship with social media right now
is
so healthy my objective for social media
now
in my life is to spread love light
laughter and positivity
like what a difference yeah what a
difference
i don't i barely check my you know my
numbers
i like to read my comments because as a
creator you love to interact with your
audience so
that's the only way i get to do it there
um but it's so healthy i only post when
i want to
i haven't i don't even think i posted
this week which is like
crazy because in my
past i would literally like stare at the
phone like with like a clock
counting down so like when the algorithm
was in the right spot for me to post
and then and then i would post and then
i'd be like oh my god
wait i have to now i have to have
something to post in six more hours what
should i do like
i was a lunatic so i'm
very grateful to say that richard is
very much like
a part of me that no longer exists which
is awesome i've done a lot of work
around
okay yeah but i'm also so happy he
exists because
it's a good tale for other people that i
know are going through this i see it all
the time
in my followers um even in my friends
sometimes i'm like y'all
need to chill and i can speak from an
enlightened place y'all
need to chill you know yeah preach
preach
no but like i i think too it's
interesting when you were just talking
about that like
feeling of checking and waiting for the
algorithm and wanting to check if you
got more likes it
really relates a lot you know old
frankie relates to
kurt in a sense and you see that even
the beginning of this film yeah kurt's
like
in such a dark d like place realizing
he's not getting the reactions he wanted
and
it sounds like you can relate a lot to
that and i think that's really just
inspiring and it kind of helps too for
people to really realize the importance
of a film like this
it's an allegory so like we get to take
what is actually happening
and it's also a pastiche which is
basically means that it's it's not only
is it
um making fun of something but it's also
illuminating
what's actually happening and it's like
the fact that an
influencer would like i mean if
i have someone in mind would take it to
the place of murder
is actually not that far of a stretch no
like i truly believe that some of the
people that have gotten famous
in this world when they lose it and when
they don't have that that it factor
anymore and they're no longer the star
of vine because vine is gone or they're
no longer the star of tick tock because
it's illegal in this country
that they are going to actually start
they would go to a place of murder
like it's not a far leap it's not a far
leap
and so i think it's why that's such a
smart movie it's a very smart smart
smart film
so in your scene it's like you were just
mentioning it's such an intense scene
and it gets crazy because
your character richard eventually gets
mauled by rabid dogs
so i'm wondering
right by the way i have photo i have
full footage of me with prosthetics on
being completely ripped apart which i
will post on my instagram
in a very healthy way don't worry that
that's going to be in the blu-ray too
yeah exactly don't worry you'll see it
but i do get mauled to death so uh
yes anyway sorry i didn't mean to
interrupt your question guys i don't
know but
my question to you is that you know you
have experience with acting and you do
so much theater and then
you know you've recently been in the
henry danger show and nickelodeon as
francini
and that's more of a recurring role so
my question is in a film like this
and you're in this important scene
you're around some big other actors and
joe carey like you said misha barton
lala ken did you feel us pressure of
having to like
put it on for this one scene you know
that it's not just like oh i can come
back
to this in another scene like this is
the scene and you got to nail it like
what was your mindset going into it yeah
well so interestingly yeah it was a
seven
it was a 12 hour shoot from 7 p.m to 7
a.m but it was only
so one day but yeah it's like you really
you get one shot at it but the
interesting thing about like when i got
the script i was literally like oh
so i don't say anything right because
there was literally like all this
description of what happens but like no
lines so i was like i guess i'm just
like a passenger in this car
and then i met with jiji and the
director and he was like oh no it's
because you're improving the whole thing
and i was like shut up and he was like
yeah and i and
eugene would text me um as he was
editing he's like this line made it in
this line made it in do you remember
when you said this this is in the film
and i saw it i was like oh my god the
stuff that i said
in this as this character is so
outrageous i literally
i actually thought that i was too i was
going too far
like i was too much like i was like
eugene
i feel like you need my friend you can't
actually be wanting me to go as big as
as i'm giving you right now and he was
like oh no this this is you're nailing
richard and i was like okay because i
again i'm not in any other scene i have
this one big scene
but i i haven't seen any of the other
actors at all
so i'm like i don't know what world i'm
in i'm just going to take the director's
word for it
and i think it really it really paid off
but um yeah in the process of doing it i
was
like yo i hope i i hope and nailed it
well especially
it was so much improv and i was shooting
myself on an iphone and there was no
director in the car
you know like eugene couldn't even see
the footage because it was being stored
on go
go pros and iphones so there was no like
monitor for him to even look at
like it was just like i don't even i
have no idea it was must have been very
difficult
for him to direct but he did a great job
no and yeah and
i'm telling you frankie you absolutely
nailed it and also
shifting gears too because just with
people
who will really follow you and know you
well you know you have such a success on
multi
platforms with youtube instagram twitter
but now it seems like you're going into
this journey of twitch
and i wonder how did this start do you
love video games and like what's kind of
been your strategy
starting out on twitch thank you for
asking about twitch i love it
um my boyfriend and i basically we
met um at oil parries which was a
it's like a this gay bar in l.a where it
was a country line dancing night
okay and um he literally wouldn't
dance with me until i proved to him that
i was a nerd which i think is hysterical
he's a gamer and he's a nerd and he was
like you don't want to dance with me
i'm a nerd and i'm a gamer and i was
like that's i'm a nerd and i'm a gamer
he was like no you're not like i don't
believe you
and i was like so i'm showing him my
tattoos on my body which are like
lord of the rings harry potter uh star
wars
star trek maleficent like i am that's
awesome
i'm a complete sci-fi nerd but no one
gets to see the side of me um
and gaming was such a big part of our
love language that i was like
you know we went to twitchcon we we
walked around we were like wow
no one looks like us like where are all
the you know
cute gay nerdy gamers like we know they
exist where are they
um and so we decided to just kind of
start our own channel and start our own
chapter and kind of
um hope that it would encourage more you
know gay people get a little bit more
visibility on the platform so that when
twitchcon does come back in
a year or two that there's like a whole
lgbt component
and that there's all these the colorful
characters and drag queens walking
around with glitter like that's kind of
our dream
um and so um and i also like it because
i want the world to see that side of me
to know that i'm a gamer to know that
i'm a nerd to know that i'm like
you know so proud of being addicted to
sci-fi fantasy
um and how much it has influenced me in
my life so
it's a nice way for me to share a side
of me that no one really associates with
me
and that's why i like twitch so much
that's amazing and
that's awesome to hear it comes from
like a deep-rooted personal
uh place and something that's of romance
and positivity and
it's also brilliant idea because again
you're filling a niche that you see is
missing so
that's really cool um now before i let
you go frankie i have one last question
for you
you you mentioned and it really caught
my uh attention when you're talking
about your
old struggles with like being kind of
hooked to social media do you have any
advice
for people because there are so many
people struggling with this that maybe
that that big problem a lot of people
have is
the fomo and fear of missing out you
know so
how have you dealt with that like how do
you deal with those feelings where we
get like the sweats where it's like oh i
haven't logged in am i missing my you
know what i mean like
yes i took away the power of social
media as the only thing that was giving
me validation in my life
you know i think that people that are
posting and checking and and
trying to be as active as they are if it
becomes unhealthy it's because they're
seeking out
external validation for you know what
who they
who they are whereas you know in my
journey through sobriety i've discovered
that
internal validation is actually the only
way to go through life and
i am so much more confident right now
than i
ever have been in my entire life and it
comes from a real genuine place and so
um i would suggest to people that are
struggling with social media to look
inward
you know to maybe meditate to do some
work on yourself and really understand
like why
am i on social media right why am i
addicted to this platform
why can't i put my phone down and then
when you answer that question about
yourself do something to change it
you know like right now i tell you about
a year ago i
a um alarm on my phone so that instagram
would turn off after one hour and i
i tell you every i used to hit that i
used to hit that mark every single day
and i can't honestly tell you the last
time i hit it i don't
know i'm yeah i haven't had that alert
that says you've been on
your phone for an instagram for an hour
in many many many months like maybe
a full like eight months nine months so
um
if you can change you really can and i
do
think that this is an important film
listen it's fun it can't be
you're going to have the time of your
life it's not preaching in any way shape
or form but i do think that it's going
to
illustrate to the world like how
negative sides of social media and you
know as a person who's lived through it
and come out
on the other side much happier and much
more joyful
a person who posts only to make people
smile and laugh and when i feel like it
rather than when
the world tells me it's a good time to
post is
it's really um it's very liberating and
there's definitely hope
and uh out there for those people that
are struggling that's
amazing points leave off on frankie
that's going to help so many people
and it's also just ties in beautifully
to this film if you haven't seen it i
don't know what you're doing
that's the biggest sell you're going to
get make sure to check
out spree now video on demand and in
drive in theaters
also check out frankie on youtube
instagram twitter and especially his
twitch
where he's been super active on it it's
uh at frankie j grande and all these and
is there anything else you want to
promote today frankie
no just everyone take care of yourself
and i would also say like you know that
these times are really difficult for
everybody out there
um you have to understand that
everything happens for a reason
covet is in front of us in order to make
a stronger people so that the next
disaster that we face and there will be
another one because it is life
that we'll be able to do it stronger and
we'll be able to do it
better so um don't lose hope don't lose
faith
like we're going to get through this
2020. 2020 is a [ __ ]
but we're going to get through it yes
we're going to be stronger for it on the
other side so
keep your head up i love it thank you
frankie i really appreciate your great
words and i hope to talk to you again
in the future we have first to know when
i have something big
definitely